[Music]
today's question comes from marissa in
new mexico marissa writes i introduced
the baby steps to my ex-boyfriend we
were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but decided to live
together
we opened a joint emergency fund account
and a joint checking account to pay our
bills and we both
brought ten thousand dollars to the
emergency fund he had no debt but i owed
4 800 bucks when we opened the checking
account so we paid that off we broke up
last week and now he wants the money
back he's calling me a thief a scammer
and is threatening to post on social
that i used all his money i'm afraid he
will make me lose my job or go to my
daughter's school to post signs saying
that i'm a thief i want to do the right
thing but it seems like since we paid
the debt when we decided to join our
incomes i do not owe him anything even
if we broke up two weeks after what is
your advice
who so sometimes dave people get tied up
in these relationships and it gets real
close and you're someone's telling me a
story and i'll stop them
and say hey
that's harassment or that's abuse and
you watch the light bulb go on and they
go oh i did
oh
right
and so i think there's something to be
said we're gonna have the conversation
about money but if you are afraid that
somebody is going to make you lose your
job if you're afraid that someone's
going to go to your kid's school and
harass them embarrass you
then you need to call the authorities
and get people involved in this
conversation because this is bigger than
you this is different than just a bad
breakup this is somebody who's you're
afraid is gonna actively try to seek to
destroy your life
so there's my little discussion on that
dave all right so help me with this
question dave what do you think
well i i
uh
i i grew up in a neighborhood where the
first thing we learned was what you do
with a bully as you hit them in the nose
you don't
give them more power right you take
their power away immediately
and so that's my uh redneck reaction
it sets your new book that's my
decoration redneck reaction that's it
just pop them in the nose and then then
they can stop and think about their
mouth okay
um but the of course we're not literally
physically recommending that these days
but um
yeah that that happened in a different
generation and um
but it sets it does set the dna of
something like this so consequently i
still to this day i i
don't uh do a good job i don't always
use good wisdom when i'm dealing with a
bully
because my first reaction is just game
on you know uh and that's not always the
best reaction yeah so that's what we're
dealing with here this guy's a bully
that's right
and um
so i don't want you to pay the 4800 even
if i thought you owed it right now
because your reason for doing it is fear
and that is not the right reason to do
it if you want to pay the 4 800 your
reason for doing it needs to be on
principle that you feel like yeah i owe
him that money i owe him that money
because the way this deal went down it's
not right and i should do it
um and i kind of think that's true yeah
i kind of think you do owe him the money
but uh but i don't want you to do it
until
your heart rate changes and drops down
because right now your heart's beating a
thousand miles a minute because you're
scared of somebody yeah right and and
that's
and he thinks and i actually don't want
him to think he got the money because of
that either is he because he bowed up on
you yeah and it's like
he's gonna he's gonna threaten you and
because then what's he gonna threaten
you for next time that's right you know
and so but um and and
so
and the other part of this is the
the the
and you can speak to this better than i
can but the
uh
uh
we were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but we moved in together
anyway which you know what that tells me
it tells me you're gonna go back yeah or
you're gonna find another emotionally
unhealthy you're gonna go back you're
gonna go back to this guy if you're not
careful and so what i want for you is
for him to never
see you speak to you or have any voices
in your head ever again correct when
this is done right uh and the next time
you see an unhealthy relationship i want
you to go no wait i'm a princess
i'm valuable
and i'm i'm so valuable that i don't
need to be entering into an unhealthy
relationship translation i don't need to
sleep with a bully all right and so
here's a couple things you can do you
can go to your boss ahead of time and
say hey
here's a good example this actually
happened dave a year ago
something back from my past came up and
i call i i emailed you right away and
said hey just so you know everything's
clear here this came up and i i
preemptively got ahead of this that
right i came and told you it ended up
being nothing nothing being a thing but
i'd go to my boss and say hey
i've got it out of control somebody's
ex-boyfriend he's going to run his mouth
and i don't know if he's going to see
you or not but just in case he did just
know you just need to know this guy's a
bozo and he'll come in looking like a
clown and you'll know he's a clown
that's right
same with the school hey if this guy
comes around call 911. get him off your
property get the security guys out here
and remove him and uh so forth
and just just be on on guard and i've
and also i've already let the
authorities know and i'm filing for a
restraining order that's right um now
once you've done all that then then
don't go back
and don't find another one to replace
him okay
so you know what do you anytime i do
something stupid i try to figure out
what it was
so i don't do it again
if i'm going to do stupid stuff it needs
to be new stupid stuff
okay that's your next book new stupid
stuff by dave ramsey we got a lot of
books coming out today okay they've been
number one bestsellers everywhere
redneck reaction and yeah new stupid
stuff but it's stupid but the uh uh but
you know the thing is that that
i i think there's a tremendous
statistical probability that she cycles
back if she doesn't break the mold on
this that's right and and it feels like
uh marissa you're trying to soft land
this thing yeah and you want to that's
fair keep this guy in the relationship
you want to figure out how to keep your
money but not have to do it's all about
you're terrified
i want you to stone cold this guy yeah
and give him the money back block him on
everything okay so let's get into that
they got together well they shouldn't
have done any of this
yeah i read um i introduced them to your
baby steps i want to say no you didn't
you like a weird part of the baby steps
well you made you up your own plan where
we can live together in an unhealthy
relationship and then combine our money
when we're not married that we have
never told anybody anything except never
do that because of this because of this
right
this is what happens when you shack up
with people you aren't married to and
you play house
because you want to wear the shoes for a
week before you actually buy them so
i've got no debt i owe 400 bucks they
paid it he he paid it off
technically i think they both they 10k
in there so there's 20 grand in there
and then they paid off 4 800 out of that
sounds like maybe she splits it he needs
to get his 10 grand back total
and it's probably down by something
yeah and then but kiddo
love yourself enough
put the stiff arm on the bozo
permanently block him on everything and
anybody that even smells like him ever
again
oh wait a minute wait a minute that i
smell bozo no
walk away